the president speech highlighted several
of his foreign policy priorities for the
year to come including a second summit
with North Korean leader Kim jong-un
that's going to come at the end of this
month CBS News senior national security
contributor Michael Morell is with us he
is a former deputy director and acting
director of the CIA Michael lots to get
who let's first talk about North Korea
the president says second summit the
intelligence assessment has said that
North Korea has no plans to give up his
nuclear weapons what should be the goal
of the summit so I think the president
deserves credit for getting us into
negotiations that's important but look
at what's happened since the first
summit right
they've stopped nuclear and missile
testing but they've made no move at all
towards denuclearization in fact we know
that they continue to do activities on
the ground to advance their program and
sanctions have weakened as other nations
have loosened to the restrictions
because things are looking better and
most importantly Kim has a seat on the
stage so what the president has to do
with the second summit is has to
incentivize or or or make clear to Kim
that he's got to move towards
negotiations or he's not going to get
another so you concerned the president
Trump will promise to formally declare
an end to the Korean War my biggest
concern is that he will cut a deal with
Kim on ICBMs right let's get rid of the
ICBMs that threatened the United States
and let's not worry so much about the
nuclear weapons that threaten the rest
of the region that's my biggest concern
speaking of weapons the president hinted
that he'd be open to negotiating a new
nuclear arms treaty with Russia after
pulling out of the recent one what
should one look like this is an
important agreement because people are
more likely to use short-range nuclear
weapons than they are a long-range is an
important agreement the Russians have
been in violation of it for some time I
think it was the right thing to do for
us to pull out of it to force a new
negotiation to bring the Russians back
in and to bring the Chinese in that's
very important because the Chinese are
doing things that are in violation of
the agreement that they're not part of
so new agreement with the Russians that
includes the Chinese right thing to do
he also says that because he also says
that because of
the work of the president and his
administration that Isis is effectively
over we don't have to worry about that
anymore you think that's true the
intelligence community made very clear
at the worldwide threat testimony last
week that Isis has not been defeated in
Syria but then he said that thousand of
them but then the president said well my
people told me that their words were
taken out of context those words are on
paper you can look at them and more
importantly yesterday the commander of
the US Central Command general Joe Votel
said not only do they remain a threat
but if we leave there's a real chance
that there will be an Isis resurgence
Joe Votel who he didn't talk to before
he made his congrats on Syria and Isis
also publicly stated that if we do leave
they would consider that a victory like
we're all great to have you think thank
you guys